en este vídeo veremos cómo sintetizar
alcoholes usando reactivos de griñán
primero tenemos que aprender cómo hacer
un reactivo de griñán y puedes empezar
con un alumno de alquilo como este en la
izquierda y añades al magnesio metálico
y necesitas añadir algo como el éter
como tu solvente no puedes tener agua
presente porque el agua reaccionará con
el reactivo de griñán y este es tu
producto aquí a la derecha acabas con un
átomo de carbono unido a un metal cierto
así que el carbono está unido al
magnesio
esto es llamado enlace órgano metálico y
puedes hacer esto con otros metales
puedes hacer esto con litio por ejemplo
pero los reactivos de griñán son una de
esas cosas de las que siempre se habla
en clases universitarias de química
orgánica y puedes ver que estos dos
electrones de aquí los rojos los que
están en rojo los he dibujado como un
enlace covalente
el enlace entre carbono y magnesio pero
realmente es más iónico que covalente es
equivalente a la segunda estructura de
aquí abajo
ahora en términos de electro negatividad
es el carbono es de hecho más electro
negativo que el magnesio de hecho los
dos electrones en rojo van a estar más
cerca al átomo de carbono dándole al
carbono una carga negativa y formando un
carbón jon entonces se forma un
no
unión
y esto es único porque este carbón puede
ahora actuar como un núcleo filo en tu
mecanismo para hacer alcoholes
esta es la preparación de un reactivo de
granger
ha demostrado ser muy muy importante en
síntesis orgánica tanto que víctor green
hart ganó el premio nobel por esta
investigación dentro de la química
observemos al mecanismo para formar un
reactivo de griñán
así que empezaré con un alumno de
alquilo
esta vez voy a dibujar todos mis pares
libres de electrones en mi halógeno
así
vamos a añadir magnesio el cual sabemos
que está en el grupo 2 el magnesio tiene
2 electrones de valencia dibujaré los 2
electrones de valencia del magnesio de
esta manera
en el primer paso del mecanismo el
magnesio donar a uno de sus electrones
cierto mostraremos el movimiento de uno
de sus electrones a este carbono
utilizaremos una flecha de media cabeza
así haremos un nuevo unión aquí porque
este carbono de hecho toma un electrón
de hecho toma una carga negativa y
llamamos a esto unión radical este
resultado intermedio es llamado unión
radical
continuaremos escribiendo eso es un
anillo
radical
a nyon porque tomo un electrón dándole
una carga negativa y es radical porque
es electrón está desaparecido así que
este año en radical es inestable y se va
a fragmentar estos dos electrones de
aquí vendrán al halógeno cierto
continuamos dibujando lo que eso nos
daría
tenemos ahora este carbono con un
electrón alrededor de él a la derecha
así
y ahora nuestro halógeno de aquí tuvo
tres pares libres acaba de tomar otro
por lo que ahora está negativamente
cargado de esta manera y el magnesio con
el que empezamos de uno un electrón por
lo que este magnesio tiene aún un
electrón alrededor un electrón de
valencia y donó un electrón lo que le da
una carga de más 1
entonces este magnesio ahora está
cargado positivamente porque dono un
electrón en el primer paso y en el
siguiente paso del mecanismo el magnesio
puede donar su segundo electrón de
valencia y se vuelve estable al hacer
eso porque entonces tendrá una
configuración electrónica de gas noble
el magnesio continuará donando su
segundo electrón de aquí al carbono así
dibujemos lo que resultaría ahora
tendremos nuestro carbono justo aquí con
tres enlaces ahora con dos electrones a
su alrededor y eso es lo que le da a su
carga formal de -1 para hacer un carbón
jon el magnesio ha donado a ambos
electrones por lo que este magnesio
es ahora un camión con una carga de más
2 m2 más así
y luego el halógeno formará un enlace
iónico con el magnesio aquí del lado
derecho tenemos nuestro halógeno que
está negativamente cargado tenemos un
magnesio con dos cargas positivas y
luego tenemos a dos moléculas con cargas
negativas a su alrededor formando en la
sesión y coss
este es nuestro carbunión y podría
volver a dibujar esto a la izquierda con
este carbono aquí puedo hacerlo un grupo
r con el par libre de electrones una
carga formal de menos 1 y todo lo de la
derecha podría sólo escribirlo de esta
manera hay varias maneras en las que
verás esto escrito podría solo decir que
esto es mgx con una carga de más 1 esto
sólo nos permite enfocarnos en este
carbono de aquí con una carga de menos 1
o podría sólo pretender que todo es
covalente
solo ahorrarme algo de tiempo podría
hacer lo siguiente
y aquellos que estudian la química
orgánica entienden lo que este compuesto
órgano metálico significa que el grupo r
está cargado negativamente como un kart
bañón verás varias maneras diferentes de
escribir un reactivo de griñán siempre y
cuando entiendas lo que está pasando eso
es lo más importante
tomemos ahora el reactivo de griñán que
acabamos de formar y hagamos un alcohol
con él
continuaré escribiendo lo igual que la
última vez realmente no importa cómo lo
haga así que esta es nuestra reacción
genérica vamos a introducir un compuesto
carbón y lo
para esta reacción genérica sólo diré
que es un carbón y lo genérico no
mostraré lo que está unido a cada lado
de mi carbono carbónico aquí y el dietil
éter
una vez más es nuestro solvente tienes
que excluir el agua de esta reacción
otra vez porque el reactivo de grillar
reaccionará con el agua en el primer
paso quiere reaccionar con tu carbón y
lo y en el segundo paso ya que haya
reaccionado con el carbón y lo está bien
añadir agua en la forma de h3 o más y
esto formará nuestro alcohol formaremos
un alcohol como nuestro producto y este
carbono de aquí vino de nuestro carbón y
no y este grupo r estará unido a ese
carbono carbónico y eso viene de nuestro
reactivo de grillar es una reacción muy
útil porque es una reacción que forma
enlaces carbono-carbono
entonces este grupo r tenía un carbono
en un extremo y luego este carbono de
aquí forman enlaces carbono-carbono es
muy importante cuando intentas formar
grandes moléculas orgánicas usando
síntesis esta es una manera muy útil de
formar alcoholes primarios secundarios o
terciarios todo depende con qué tipo de
compuesto carbon y lo estás empezando
mostramos el mecanismo de lo que está
pasando
diré que el reactivo de griñán es una
fuente de carbón es cierto solo dibujaré
mi carbunión aquí de esta manera y luego
mi carbón y lo tengo el carbono con un
doble enlace al oxígeno
y haré esto ya sabes cualquier cosa
puede estar unida al carbono por ahora
una vez más cuando estás viendo química
de carbón y los todo lo que tienes que
hacer es pensar sobre diferencias en
electro negatividad entre carbono y
oxígeno así que regresa y observa el
vídeo de electro negatividad
sabemos que el oxígeno siendo más
electro negativo jalar a estos
electrones en el doble enlace cerca de
él dándole una carga parcial negativa
dejando a nuestro carbón o parcialmente
positivo bien el carbono siendo
parcialmente positivo el carbono quiere
electrón es cierto el carbono es electro
físico y de nuestro reactivo de grignard
tenemos un núcleo fino el carbón va a
actuar como un núcleo fino la carga
negativa es atraída a la carga positiva
por lo que el carbayón ataca el carbono
carbónico así
lo que mandar a estos electrones a
nuestro oxígeno y dibujaré el resultado
intermedio aquí ahora tenemos ahora
tenemos nuestro grupo r directamente
unido a nuestro lo que solía ser nuestro
carbono carbónico y ahora nuestro
oxígeno tiene tres pares libres de
electrones alrededor lo que le da a
nuestro oxígeno una carga formal de
menos 1 así
ese es el primer paso de nuestra
reacción en el segundo paso tenemos
iones y drones flotando alrededor h tres
o más dibujaré h tres o más aquí así y
el segundo paso por supuesto será
química ha sido base un par libre de
electrones en nuestro oxígeno toma un
protón del h tres o más dejando estos
electrones atrás para formar agua y así
es cómo obtenemos nuestro alcohol eso
nos dará nuestro alcohol como producto
después de nuestra reacción ácido base
miremos tres ejemplos diferentes de
síntesis de alcoholes
y mostremos los diferentes tipos de
alcoholes que pueden producirse
y empezaremos con el formaldehído
empezaremos con una molécula muy simple
como ésta
y continuaremos haciendo nuestro
reactivo de griñán y vamos a hacer
bromuro de metilo magnesio
añadiremos el bromuro de metilo magnesio
en nuestro primer paso lo utilizaremos
como nuestro solvente y en nuestro
segundo paso añadiremos h3o más ahora
cuando estás analizando un reactivo de
griñán debes pensar dónde está mi carbón
por lo que este carbono de aquí está
cargado negativamente
ese es el carbono que va a atacar a mi
carbón y lo este carbono ataca mi carbón
y lo
y los electrones se mueven acá como
nuestro producto intermedio
tendremos hidrógenos en cada lado de
nuestro carbono un oxígeno negativamente
cargado aquí arriba y el grupo r esta
vez en un grupo metilo como esto
después de protón arlo en el segundo
paso después de esto sólo diremos que
este par libre de electrones tomará un
protón del h 3 o más
formaremos este carbono con dos
hidrógenos vamos a proponer nuestro al
cocido para formar un alcohol aquí
arriba para nuestro producto y si
observas esa molécula detenidamente
notarás que es etanol cierto formas
alcoholes primarios
si usas formaldehídos entonces este es
un alcohol primario es primario porque
el carbono unido a lo h está unido a un
carbono más veamos cómo podemos hacer
alcoholes secundarios
esta vez necesitas empezar con un
aldehído por lo que en lugar de dos
hidrógenos en cada lado de tu carbono
como lo hicimos antes esta vez necesitas
tener un grupo r en un lado este será
nuestro aldehído
así
bien ahora usemos ese mismo reactivo de
griñán usamos bromuro de metilo magnesio
de nuevo así
el segundo paso h
más una vez más piensa en cuál es tu
núcleo filo así que mi carbono cargado
negativamente va a ser mi núcleo filo va
a atacar mi carbón hilo y mover a estos
electrones
nuevamente cuando dibujamos el producto
intermedio aquí arriba tenemos nuestro
unión al cosido negativamente cargado el
hidrógeno aún está ahí y lo que hicimos
fue añadir un grupo metilo
este ch3 abajo de nuestro producto
intermedio vino de nuestro reactivo de
griñán y una vez más química ácido base
para protón ar el alcohol sido
formaremos nuestro alcohol secundario de
esta manera
ese será él
alcohol secundario que se produce de la
reacción nuevamente este carbono está
unido a otros 2 carbonos haciéndolo un
alcohol secundario bien hagamos un
ejemplo más aquí esta vez vamos a
reaccionar nuestro reactivo de griñán
con una acetona empezaremos con un
acetona a la izquierda aquí está nuestra
acetona es una ciclohexano na y otra vez
quedémonos con el bromuro de metilo
magnesio
y añadimos bromuro de metilo magnesio y
otra vez nuestro solvente está
excluyendo agua y el segundo paso
en el segundo paso añadiremos una fuente
de protones h 3 o más una vez más
exactamente el mismo mecanismo
exactamente el mismo pensamiento
involucrado cierto nuestro carvalho
encargado negativamente ataca a nuestro
carbono carbónico moviendo estos
electrones hacia nuestro oxígeno bien
entonces formamos nuestro producto
intermedio por lo que este oxígeno de
aquí arriba
ahora tiene
tres pares libres de electrones y está
cargado negativamente
de hecho déjame continuar y quitar esto
de aquí para que podamos mostrar mejor
los átomos unidos al carbono carbónico
si estoy mostrando
es el grupo metilo atacando ese carbón y
lo empujar e s al cox ido de aquí un
poco a la izquierda
y eso tomará mi carga negativa
y de esta manera eso solo me da un poco
de espacio para poner mi grupo metilo
aquí así y eso solo se ve un poco más
parecido a cómo se vería mi producto
final este par libre de electrones como
siempre este par libre uno de estos
pares libres va a tomar un protón
y eso formará nuestro producto bien
ahora pro tomamos nuestro al cocido para
formar nuestro alcohol así nuestro
alcohol se formará justo aquí y luego
nuestro grupo metilo se añade aquí
y si observas detenidamente puedes ver
que acabamos de hacer un alcohol
terciario
bien este carbono
está conectado a 123 carbonos por lo que
los reactivos de green hart son muy
útiles para hacer alcoholes y puedes
hacer tanto alcoholes primarios
secundarios o terciarios de ellos es un
reactivo muy versátil en el siguiente
vídeo veremos más sobre reactivos de
griñán y hablaremos un poco sobre cómo
trabajar al revés y pensar en problemas
de síntesis